[Music]
after facing unprecedented challenges in
the first six months of the year
europe is embarking on the road to
recovery parliament wants green and
ambitious solutions to make europe
stronger after the
19 pandemic mep's top
priorities are to see an agreement on
the 750 billion euro coronavirus
recovery plan
and the completion of the 2021 to 2027
budget
to help fund the budget parliament wants
new revenues from sources like attacks
on plastic waste
and a common corporation
[Music]
is to reflect
new priorities caused by the pandemic
the industrial strategy will be updated
to integrate the recovery plan
parliament says the eu must prioritize
sectors which will create green jobs
while protecting competition and the
internal market
safeguarding the environment in all
future legislation will be a common
thread of the second half of the year
thanks to the green deal a central
element of the negotiations on the
climate law
will be targets parliament wants a 55
reduction of co2 emissions by 2030
closely linked to the european green
deal is the update of the common
agricultural policy
it aims to rethink our food chain ensure
farmers
income and preserve biodiversity meps
will make sure this goes hand in hand
with sustainable and climate neutral
growth
parliament wants to hear europeans
priorities for shaping the eu of
tomorrow
it is calling for the conference on the
future of europe to begin
after the summer an update to rail
passenger rights should be finalized by
the end of the year
meps want easier train access for
disabled people and cyclists
and better protection of passengers
rights
migration is a major challenge for the
eu parliament will look at the new
asylum and migration pact
once the commission presents its plan
meps have already made clear they want
safe and legal routes
including for labour related migration
europa league
as the year draws to a close so will the
brexit transition period which ends on
the 31st of december
over the coming months meps will have
their say on the future relationship
with the uk
any agreement must get parliament's
approval we will need to step up
our no deal preparations the european
parliament
will not agree to a deal at
any cost